looks good
sup it's me mark with your boy
ethan and tyler
we're going to be doing some easter
what's his year about
love
we're celebrating the death gather round
gather round
children gather round we're here to talk
about something very special today
oh easter eggs
now when i was a child i couldn't afford
to do easter eggs we couldn't even
afford eggs we had a chicken but then we
had to kill it for our own entertainment
so uh i am here to relive the history of
easter and the easter bunny and the
easter bunny and how he affects our
lives to this very day
do you know how to make an easter egg
shove an egg up
regurgitate it out and then it's
colorful i mean it will be colorful
yes traditionally in ancient germany
they used to gather all the rabbits in
the countryside
germany hey which one of us is german
uh a little bit mr fishbach
it's the german right
listen in ancient germany they gathered
rabbits all around the campfire they
gathered some eggs
and they just started shoving and they
shoved and they shoved and they shoved
and it was like a pinata except instead
of hitting it they kept shoving until it
exploded
and all the children ran around with
their mouths open like i'm getting some
and i'm getting some
some of this german soul i've been i've
been getting salmonella
and then they caught them and then you
know uh
they celebrated easter i remember
so we don't have any rabbits
unfortunately but we do have a tyler so
we're gonna stuff them full of eggs as
hard as we can until he explodes
oh yeah those will help cut the bottom
out it'll be a funnel yeah
shove them in there so uh we're gonna
make it i
honestly have no idea what the hell
what is this wait what is this what is
that
i don't know what is this color whip
what with color with food safe foam
what boom don't you just put an egg into
a thing and then it's
colorful no that's stupid you're stupid
okay do we have eggs we have eggs we
have bags right
uh we have eggs tyler lay an egg we have
the pops
it's german what does it mean poss piss
ass ass
because it's a special day it's easter
day
put your piss ass ass into your
celebration bowl
whisk it up no that's for the foam oh i
don't know why i don't know
why did they cut it here i don't know
should i put this in here
i'm sure yeah you know what i guess
you're you're doing foam
all right that goes there the piss ass
ass was
gonna die why'd you pour it so high
don't blow it it's okay it's contained
okay so i need a third of a cup let's do
a guessing game
did we start yeah sure
we haven't started yet we haven't done
we haven't even introduced what we're
doing
you told me to put in the mixing no you
said to yourself
should i put it in the mixing bowl and
you went
no okay you wait
you said yes i didn't know what i was
saying yes to man
you can't say that i told you to do that
i asked for permission
and papa said sure
oh god oh
listen listen what are you doing
making die all right
here's the rules we're gonna make three
just three delightful eggs
as delightful as you want they are your
babies
these eggs are going to be your babies
these eggs are your babies babies
they're your babies they're my babies
and your kids have a weight seeing your
baby i'm literally saying your babies
can i have a wish
this is not a whistle
[Music]
i've lost
listen guys you're not listening stop
mixing just dry powder
but doesn't it taste good
today is the day i die how many years
did you just take off your life from
this
assets what was it celebrate with an s
okay you're gonna pick three eggs for
the love of god listen to me
we haven't said go we haven't started we
haven't done nothing
how many makes have we done two
we're gonna pick three eggs we are on
our own to
decorate yes three eggs a piece we're on
our own to decorate them we'll get 10
minutes
to dye them decorate them in whatever
way you can do the best of your
abilities and at the end of them
we will judge them makes sense makes
sense sound fair
all right you can divvy up the not not
going yet but just
you can have the the cups in front of
you for the die
and the yachty and the whatever
[Music]
go
go go oh this isn't
good oh
[Applause]
what one are you making thanks
i'm making boom
[Laughter]
good for you okay okay
[Laughter]
no one makes ethan laugh i think
inhaling
no this friendly
friendly eight minutes oh god the last
time i decorated eggs
was as a child and i i don't really
remember it but
i'm trying to follow what it's saying
what the what the hell did you do got a
lot of colors going on a little bit
every color oh my god
you didn't read the instructions i did
it a little
[Laughter]
so i was given a tray i'm assuming that
means
i'm gonna hand drop these colors onto it
oh this is staining
but i'm gonna hand drop them on and then
that's
what they're gonna be mine's coming into
fruition
i'm gonna leave him in there for a
minute three eggs good enough
add some time to this no no no no no no
how much time we get how much time we
get what are we looking at
that's fine plenty of time
let's pause the time real quick just
pause it because we need to talk about
some things
we're having a family meeting everybody
family family meeting
don't you look at whatever i'm doing
shut up
are we in trouble yes you're all you've
been very naughty the both of you
look at me when i'm talking to you not
with that face
no no no no there we go and look at me
can you look at me
you've been very naughty been bad this
easter
oh do it again
oh you do not
me you
all right have you learned your lesson
yeah all right
good go
we're gonna go for five minutes okay
that sounds good
well mine are baking so how you guys
doing
i think i did something wrong was this
supposed to be vinegar it was supposed
to move in there
not the whole thing okay but this much
times two
and it was supposed to go everybody go
away you're gonna spill that
on the floor no i'm not no i'm not no
i'm not oh look at me tyler how's yours
going
they're soaking like good little
children i think that's something
that's gonna be cool
i'm back hey
hi we're giving that vinegar
we got three minutes yep
how's your incoming how's my coming oh
you know
comes and goes how many eggs three eggs
yes three eggs what are you doing i'm
just waiting
for one time to do its thing you know
how time works
just now it's the easter bunny
what kind of chaos world has this become
do i have to take my eggs out within the
minute or after the minute can i take
them out
all right huh rule maker
i'll give you another 10 minutes another
10.
how about another five all for an hour
once an hour
well the rule maker has spoken maybe you
know
just when we're done we're done yo art
can't be rushed
i need
i vinegar realized what i was doing
there's a pool of pink dye
inside here now so i can't layer colors
like i thought it was gonna do
oh what are you doing
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
that's supposed to be foam how much time
do we have there's no timer anymore
i don't like living under this kind of
freedom i need a time constraint
i need to feel the guillotine above my
neck why are these wet
oh it's because i spilled water
all right i'm gonna do an experiment
with one i'm gonna put it in boiling
water
what will happen whoa whoa whoa my
boiling water your own
no oh no
it cracked don't worry about it
oh it's boiling water out that change
colors
yeah i did i don't know how i'll just
rest you right there little guy
i'm done done i'm finished
you have a minute left i have one minute
you have one minute
after the first person finishes there's
one minute
what was your thought process obviously
there wasn't one
what is it when that's an egg that makes
everything really just go downhill
last egg thing we were fine you spread
your disease
your egg-based disease to me it hasn't
quite reached tyler yet
but next time we do an egg thing no he
got me it splattered on my face
the bottom of your child is on my face
what's the time
[Applause]
yeah ethan you go first all three eggs
are we presenting yeah sure all right
here they are we've got
egg he's got an egg written all over him
we've got number two
he is i call him hot
he's graduating yeah yeah that's what
he's doing
then we have the last one that turned
pink he's got a little spewage going on
but that doesn't mean that he doesn't
like to party you know okay
larry berry and scary that's it
[Applause]
mine are themed you've got mama bunny
egg
with their two beautiful themed boys
yeah okay all right
but we are not judging them on
appearance at all
appearance has nothing to do with this
we're we're judging these on
strength strength of will strength of
ability
it doesn't matter how pretty they are
how they look this is war
and my champions larry berry and scary
are gonna crush the snot out of your
eggs who's going first
i don't know what we're doing who's
going first i'll go
first all right who do you volunteer i
volunteer egg
hi volunteer barry we're at war we fight
whichever one breaks first
dies ready yeah set
go
no way actually
ready go
come on yeah yeah
hang on [ __ ] you die
die give me that
yeah barry this body will remain all
right on the battlefield
all right who's gonna go up against
barry blue boy
blue boy's gonna go all right here we go
barry no barry barry no
no leave his corpse there
the shine all right graduated
life [ __ ]
oh no his armor
yes graduation
all right larry larry it's time to
avenge your brother barry
[Laughter]
you're getting shined towards you all
right
are we doing right
well mine's already done yeah bring it
on i'm going to take off his cap
well he lost forfeit sorry i help him no
you don't know anything oh he's risking
it
all right
go until he breaks
no
[Laughter]
i think oh broken i think he's broken i
think he broke all right
it's up to you scary your brothers need
to be avenged
no it's with the winner takes off
no scary kill come on
giant boy now they have to fight
brothers no mother
oedipus no
she killed her mother mother's dying
just squishing in her face
the war's brutal man
[Laughter]
finish
[Music]
plastic and we have a winner
the the blood the blood thirsty golden
egg
here terrain supreme over all the dead
thank you everybody for joining us for
this easter special
hope you enjoyed it this year was
special it sure was
special thank you all for a wonderful
time with markiplier makes
and remember even if it's not the
prettiest egg
well in this case the prettiest egg won
but
even if it's not the prettiest egg it
can still fight
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out ethan's channel at
crank game plays
tyler's got a twitch over at apocalypto
underscore 12
and i'm markiplier and as always we'll
see you in the next one
bye-bye